hey guys welcome back to your weekly
dead stream recap today and it was
mostly a jam-packed kind of dead stream
mostly about more ranked info and then a
new patch that's coming out next week so
let's not waste any time let's get
started with this so first off any
players on all platforms who were
affected by the bug a couple days ago
and didn't receive any rewards after
completing matches this week the
compensation gifts for all of us is a 3d
champ 3-day champion status and one
premium crate but Xbox one players also
were affected by two bugs that exact
week so they're going to be getting
three day champion status and two
premium crates so that's their
compensation gift next up is the new
weekly content which is new battle
outfits for all heroes which I'll show
to you right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
so those were the outfits
since the vows are kind of different
since these are battle outfits the first
outfit that was displayed is going to
cost 3,000 steal the second outfit is
1,500 steal and the third outfit is
going to be 5,000 steal these are battle
outfits and I'm not really sure I'm
going to be buying these they're not
really worth to steal but maybe they are
to you guys
really let's get continue on so next up
they did Keys a little bit about a new
patch coming up called patch 1.09 it's
going to be releasing next week for PC
in council a few days later Ubisoft
never stated what's going to be in the
patch but they did say they're going to
talk majority about it on the Dead
stream next week so be prepared for that
next I brought in one of their game
designers to talk about the new rank
system for ranked mode ranked mode is
basically going to be based off your
personal performance instead of team
cooperation so for example if you and
your teammate or playing in brawl and
you win the brawl match and you get more
kills and you practically carry them to
a win both you're going to receive more
points to get up to your next ranking
but you're going to receive more because
you helped him more you got more kills
you did more stuff so you're going to
get more points toward that reward it's
also going to be listed in five
divisions and five tiers I'm assuming
the divisions are bronze silver gold
platinum diamonds I believe and there's
also going to be five tiers so for
example you could be gold three but tier
four so that means once you hit tier
five you're going to be gold for four on
overall subtract and show you how close
you are to D ranking and ranking up
instead of just predicting when you're
going to like other games do but to get
into these games you're also going to
get into these rankings you're also
going to need to play twenty qualifier
matches I know that's a bit weird but to
get I know it's to whole get like a
better understanding of what our actual
rank is but I feel like twenty games is
going to be a lot because remember this
isn't just dual matches there's also
Dominion and Dominion games take about
like 10 to 15 minutes to complete so
just times that number by 20 and you're
going to be sitting there for 3-4
definitely more than four hours trying
to get all 20 of your games completed so
it must be a hassle
who knows maybe it's only for dual maybe
dominions maybe ten matches but we don't
know exactly yet until it's going to be
released next up they brought in Damion
to talk about the new public test server
now this is only going to be for PC
players so if you want
PC you can skip this I'll leave a
timestamp right below and you can click
to that we can go to the Q&A with Roman
but if you don't care enough if you're
on PC or you just don't want to listen
for the information let's get started
they're releasing this public test so
that you can check if they do it they
can check out the duel tournament is
working as intended and seeing that the
rank system is also working as intended
the duel tournament has no gear stats
ranking is enabled and the whole
tournament seems to be around 30 to 90
minutes of completion so you might want
to set up some free time in your
schedule if you want to participate in
terms of the technology they want to see
how the tournament flows and will
incorporate the quarter penalty but only
if you abandon the tournament because
there is a brief period where you have
time to come back to the game and not
receive a loss and they also have
routers put up so that they can prevent
cheating and DDoS attacks during the
matches the example you're seeing is two
pools of four different teams so 18 is
in total battling in a tournament in
each team plays the other teams of their
pool and determine who is going to be
first second third or last in their
tournament and that is going or in their
pool and that's going to be determined
by the points you get you win so you get
three points for every time you win and
you get zero points for when you lose so
if you were to ace the entire pool you'd
get nine points second place you
probably get six third would have three
points and fourth place would probably
have zero if you're in first place in
your group or pool you would fight the
team who's in first place of the other
pool to determine who wins the whole
tournament usually this only example has
two but I believe for the actual
tournament is going to be 32 teams in
four pools so there's got four pools
yeah there's going to be 32 teams it's
going to be tons of pools and tons of
competition to see who is the best
player this is going to be a lot of time
into these duels so just like I said set
a lot of time in your schedule to be
prepared to win this tournament or not
I'm also going to be showing you guys a
video also of what happens if you happen
to win the tournament this little mock
video they put up together they showed a
just kind of like a brief summary of
what would happen if you win the
tournament and in this tournament the
player received the legendary tier award
which was a Kent's a tournament just for
example as the higher you go up in the
tournament the higher tier over words
you'll get for example mid mid to like
upper
your reward would be versatile and then
the highest here would be legendary yes
they understand the memes we all throw
at them at the versatile for lawbreaker
and the legendary writer so that's why
they named it after that so I'm glad
they do know about that but you can also
check at the end of the game the
qualifier and playoff summary to see
where you won and lost and then the
stats of other players to maybe help you
get better at the game and probably just
overall kind of congratulate the player
or just somehow help your skill in the
match now you can play as many
tournaments as you want in this public
test see what confuses me is that this
is only on PC this is starting on June
on July 29th at 9 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time and it will end on July 4th at 5
p.m. Pacific Standard Time once again I
don't know where any of you live I don't
know your time zones I only don't mind
even though I am an xbox I will not be
able to participate but it is Pacific
Standard Time at 9 a.m. on July 29th and
then it's will end on July 4th at 5 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time you can look at
your time zone and discover all that out
I won't be able to be playing on xbox
since I am on the council so I'm going
to have I'm either going to be looking
at some gameplay of other people on on
the PC or any of you guys can tell me
during this how it's been going on just
so I can get a deal of is it working is
it not working and the purpose of this
is the whole test is that they can
prepare the game for ranked mode and
making sure it's as smooth and isn't
buggy as possible so that so give them
as much feedback as you can and help
them improve it on the forums on reddit
they're always going to be looking
throughout this whole duration of this
period so please be sure to give them as
much info as possible alright so now
that everybody's back we can now talk
about the QA with Roman and to basically
sum it up
Centurion might be receiving a nerf in
4v4 modes in patch 1.09 next week so
just making the tracking on the jab a
lot better so it's easier to dodge but
this data will be talked about more
during the dev stream tomorrow next week
revenge for duels will be disabled to
make it more balanced it will also be
taken out of the duel tournament people
also complained why there's more neutral
colors than attacker and defending color
so that's also going to be addressed I
never seem to have a problem with it but
I guess some people do enjoy therefore
on our fashion Ubisoft is also invest
getting and making sure players keep XP
when disconnecting during matches so
that would definitely help and they're
also possibly adding a system to make
people spend their Salvage and not
trying hoarding at all I know a lot of
you probably play more than I do but I
have about 90,000 or 90,000 to a hundred
thousand worth of samurai steel just
held up there and I'm kind of waiting to
spend it all so this is definitely be a
good type of system to add an ubisoft is
also looking to adding more cosmetics
for higher rep characters kind of
differentiate because because the I
guess a lot of people are having
problems with like hey I'm a rep 20
beserker
and then this rep 3 berserker has just
the amount of gear that I do we look the
same it's just that I'm 17 rep levels
higher than him there should be a
difference so they might add specific
rep levels or specific cosmetics or
something like that at a certain rep
level like maybe it's really cool
ornament at only rep 20 or above that
you have to be that high to get it or
something like that so who knows maybe
it'll come out well that all probably
talks about next week which I will cover
you just like I always do but that's
going to be the end of the video today
guys like I said if you guys do enjoy
this video please be sure to give it a
like if you disliked it dislike it if
you're new to this channel subscribe I
always do the dev stream recaps I was
put out for our content and then next
week is going to be view lawbreakers
beta so you're going to see a little bit
of that gameplay it is going to be weird
I know but just bear with me I just do I
do want to cover a bit more games than
for honor I'm not stopping for honor
like I've always stayed in and just I've
always wanted to add this just to get
more gameplay get more stuff on this
channel so trust me I'm not stopping for
honor but anyway guys if you all did
enjoy like this like all that stuff my
video my new my oldest video will be
popping up in the top right for you to
look at and then I'll see you all later
and peace out